[Música]
amigas acá estamos y con este gran
público queríamos empezar preguntándoles
caras de qué profesión tenemos
levanten la mano quienes piensan que
somos ingenieras
[Música]
quienes piensan que estamos vivas
un par más y quienes piensan que somos
abogadas
abbas no parece mar y que hoy tenemos un
público que está conectado con nuestras
ideas porque si somos biólogas somos
biólogas somos docentes investigadoras
mamás pero si hay algo que creo que
tampoco saben son nuestros nombres y
vieron que hay nombres que se relacionan
con las profesiones por ejemplo o
apellidos mejor dicho por ejemplo el
arquitecto paredes asumimos que nos va a
dejar la pared derecha o el geólogo roca
que en esta zona se encuentra la roca
madre de petróleo estaría muy bien
posicionado y en nuestro caso mi amiga
se llama marina marina la bióloga marina
que estudia la biodiversidad marina los
mamíferos marinos y yo nadie nadie sola
nadie me podría haber llamado no sé
jazmín violeta o de apellido flores de
última pero no nadie
y hay algo que no les estás contando su
segundo nombre saben cuál es la soledad
de nadie soledad pero somos bióloga y si
hay algo que sí nos une con mi amiga es
una profunda pasión y respeto por
nuestra biodiversidad y cuando decimos
nuestra es porque nos estamos refiriendo
a toda esa biodiversidad que vemos pero
que no miramos bueno para compartir un
poco con ustedes qué es lo que hacemos
con esto de ser bióloga les contamos que
hace un tiempo empezamos a trabajar en
punta márquez punta mar que se encuentra
en la zona central este de la patagonia
argentina en el golfo san jorge
y es un acantilado que está al sur de la
localidad de rada tilly
este acantilado alberga una colonia de
los marinos de un pelo que es permanente
y en el año 1985 se crea la reserva
punta márquez para darle protección a
esta especie
en este momento la colonia estaba
conformada por unos 300 individuos y hoy
hay más de 3500 además en la actualidad
se observan nacimientos
y acompañando a estos preciosos lobos
marinos yo creo que todos ustedes habrán
visto unos hermosos arbustos patagónicos
o matas patagónicos estos arbustos y
estos pastos que tienen aspecto
achaparrado espinas hojas reducidas
flores de colores no muy llamativas
siempre me llamaron la atención porque
están ahí todo el tiempo bajo las
inclemencias del clima que son inviernos
extremadamente fríos con precipitaciones
y veranos muy secos sin lluvias y con
fuertes vientos aún así estas plantas
pueden completar su ciclo biológico
tener flores frutos semillas y sin
moverse pueden hacer todo esto en un
clima muy particular así que supongo que
habrán visto estas hermosas matas
patagónicas y que estarían a la par de
los mamíferos marinos no hablamos nada
todavía esto de los mamíferos miren
estas ballenas alguno de ustedes sabían
que las podemos observar acá frente a
comodoro frente a rada tilly
y si miramos bien van a ver quién es la
ballena franca que siguen también la
vemos pasar por por acá fíjense que
estas ballenas tienen una aleta dorsal a
este grupo de ballenas se denominan
ballenas rorcuales muy interesante lo de
los mamíferos marinos pero creo que no
mencionas tiene que son los rorcuales
mar y bueno como te decía además de esta
letra dorsal las ballenas rorcuales
tiene un pliegue en garganta y en la
región ventral que se expanden cuando
tragan agua para alimentarse y que
después de filtrada por las barbas un
dato no menor es que alguna de estas
especies se encuentran hoy en peligro de
extinción bueno me parece que la verdad
mari que los mamíferos marinos tenemos
que reconocer que son muy carismáticos y
llamativos pero la verdad que patagonia
no sería patagonia sin sus matas sin sus
arbustos y sus pastos patagónicos pero
si hay algo que nos unió aún más fue
enterarnos que alrededor del área
natural protegida punta márquez de
nuestra área natural protegida existían
diversos proyectos de urbanización
y van a instalar en los alrededores
sí mientras pensamos en presentar
proyectos de investigación en hacer
salidas a la naturaleza en trabajar para
ampliar nuestra área protegida nos
enteramos que cerca del área había
proyectos de urbanizaciones como se
imaginan se nos vino el mundo abajo se
nos vinieron un montón de preguntas como
por ejemplo qué pasará con la colonia de
lobos seguirá creciendo como lo veíamos
viendo en los últimos años
el avistaje de los cetáceos seguirá
siendo frecuente el paisaje comenzaría a
fragmentarse y ahí nos dimos cuenta que
el área natural protegida quedaría
encerrada entre urbanizaciones
imagínense sería una isla rodeada por
casas y cuando todas estas sensaciones
nos invadían fue que nos dimos cuenta
que no estábamos solas y conocimos a un
grupo de vecinos que al igual que
nosotras tenía el mismo objetivo el de
preservar y conservar esta zona para que
siga siendo un espacio compartido y
recreativo
y muchas de las historias que nos
contaron que comparten el mismo espacio
físico y que tienen que ver con momentos
emotivos le dieron aún más sentido de
las investigaciones que realizamos
algunas de estas historias queremos hoy
compartir con ustedes
gustavo desde adolescente pescando con
sus amigos tirando en la red
o sophie la hija de cristian que
aprendió a nadar en estas costas y que
es el lugar que eligen con su papá para
compartir momentos
silvia y su pasión por observar a la
colonia de los marinos
lety sus caminatas por la playa al
atardecer compartiendo un asado con
gustavo
priscila y su fin de año compartiendo
con sus primas conociendo la
biodiversidad de la flora y de la fauna
del lugar o malú siendo adolescente y
acampando al reparo de unas hampa de un
arbusto patagónico
y otra de las historias que nos conmovió
aún más fue la historia de pamela para -
contó con sus ojos llenos de lágrimas
que es una de las únicas playas a las
cuales podía acceder su mamá en silla de
ruedas y no nos podemos olvidar de las
historias que compartieron con nosotros
los pueblos originarios y saber que en
esas playas descansan sus ancestros que
también son nuestros ancestros todas
estas historias que hoy compartimos con
ustedes nos interpelaron y nos
interpelan hoy para que asumamos una
actitud de compromiso y de respeto con
la biodiversidad que nos rodea
hay datos muchos datos que son
alarmantes según la unión internacional
para la conservación de la naturaleza de
casi 64 mil especies evaluadas 20 mil se
encuentran en peligro crítico de
extinción esto qué quiere decir quiere
decir que es muy probable que en los
próximos años estas especies
desaparezcan argentinas a nuestro país
tiene un gran número de correcciones sin
embargo la pérdida del hábitat y la
fragmentación de los ecosistemas son dos
de las principales amenazas para la
biodiversidad como ejemplo de esto
podemos mencionarles que actualmente hoy
en argentina bajo el programa de
extinción cero se preservan tres
especies de aves 2 mamíferos un anfibio
y un pez que actualmente hoy se
encuentran en peligro de extinción y que
podrían desaparecer chubut nuestra
provincia tiene el 13 por ciento de su
territorio bajo protección sin embargo
estas urbanizaciones en zonas
vulnerables pondrían en peligro la
continuidad del sistema sabemos que
perder la biodiversidad
natural protegida apunta a márquez y el
hábitat de sus alrededores no solo
representaría un problema ecológico y
ambiental sino que iría pagando cada una
de las historias que hoy compartimos con
ustedes
si al igual que una cadena de favores
esta cadena de historias logrará
multiplicar nuestro compromiso como
especie humana la fuerza de unión será
imparable por eso con maryna hoy
queremos pedirles que con tu historia
formes parte de un eslabón único y
poderoso de esta cadena para que sea lo
suficientemente fuerte como para
proteger el área natural de punta
márquez y potenciar nuestra identidad
estamos convencidas de que no tenemos
más tiempo ya vimos como las máquinas en
cuestión de días degradaron el suelo y
la vegetación del lugar
necesitamos queremos seguir sumando
historias para que el área natural
protegida punta mar que siga siendo
nuestro lugar tu lugar un lugar
compartido
[Aplausos]
[Música]